ondeando grandes banderas de brasil en
la playa de copacabana así celebraron
los seguidores de jair bolsonaro el
aniversario del golpe militar de 1964 un
periodo que el presidente de
ultraderecha ha enaltecido en repetidas
ocasiones pero la reunión de la extrema
derecha generó el rechazo de muchos
ciudadanos provocando choques entre los
manifestantes y algunos transeúntes en
río de janeiro
la gente quiere democracia no dictadura
fuera bolsonaro
[Aplausos]
nosotros estamos pidiendo la
intervención militar estamos pidiendo la
intervención federal con el presidente
bolsonaro en el poder
la señalada fecha llega en plena crisis
del gabinete presidencial de bolsonaro
quien ha reemplazado a seis altos cargos
ministeriales y a tres comandantes de
las fuerzas armadas en la última semana
proyectando gran inestabilidad desde el
gobierno todo mientras el país
sudamericano se enfrenta el peor momento
epidemiológico desde el inicio de la
pandemia algo que amenaza con perjudicar
gravemente la economía nacional con el
índice de desempleo disparado un tema
que preocupa más al mandatario que la
crisis sanitaria
cualquiera puede contraer el virus
cualquiera puede ver agravado su estado
de salud pero el hambre mata mucho más
que el propio virus
no obstante brasil sigue batiendo
récords de contagios y muertes diarias
con más de 3800 decesos en el último día
en regiones como sao paulo han tenido
que empezar a celebrar funerales durante
la noche para dar abasto a todos los
entierros